Culture is,
uh,
frankly,
um,
one of the reasons why many of the
developing nations of the world continue
to kind of depend on handouts for the,
because they do not have an agricultural
infrastructure that allows them to be
self sufficient in food production is,
and,
and in the area of global trade,
um,
we really do not have very much free
trade and agriculture because it's an
interesting phenomena.
No matter how,
no matter how rich or country is,
most farmers will want to protect what
they have inside.
It's as true of America.
It's true of the UK,
it's true of Europe.
It's true of China's true of everywhere
else.
So agriculture is probably the reason
why we cannot move very aggressively on
a new global trade round.
The agricultural interests are,
are pretty down on.
Well,
I think in the area of agriculture,
uh,
you know,
what we as a nation have to do this
after recognize that vast areas of the
world has subsistence agriculture and
our policies tend to hurt that because
of the way we subsidize our products.
I don't want to make an overall
statement because some are more in that
area than an than others.
And not every one of our programs is
bad.
But,
um,
agriculture is unique.
The politics of agriculture is unlike
any in the rest of the world.
You can be talking to the most liberal,
progressive politician in America or
Japan or in Europe on anything else.
And you mentioned dairy or cotton or
sugar,
and it's like they turned from Dr Jekyll
and Mr. Hyde.
It's just,
it's just the way of the world and has
probably always been that way.
And part of it is this natural
predilection to protect your farmers and
your food supply.